FORMENTON PLAYS IT BACK, ENNIS
BROUGHTND KHUDOBIN COMES
ACROSS AND JOSH NORRIS CAN'T
BELIEVE HELPING OUT AND THEN RI
THERE,
SCORES!HE NET.
THAT LEAVES RAFFL WIDE OPEN IN
AT IDE PAST KHUDOBIN.
RYAN SUTER TRIES TO GO BETWEENS
POINT, HARD SHOT, KHUDOBIN
KNOCKEDD THE OTTAWA SENATORS.
THERE WERE LEAN YEARS IN THERE
BUT HE
BROWN, LEAVES IT THERE F
AND IT NEVER HAPPENED ABOT,
WRIST SHOT FELL AT CENTRE ICE AD
THAT BROKE UP THAT RIDE.
BACK TO LINDELL WITH A WRIST
SHOT, BOUNCING PUCK IN FRONT,
RADULOV C
THE STANDS RIGHT NOW.
TO SEE THE SUPPORT WE HAVE RIGHT
NOW.3:31 TO GO IN THE
OPENING PERIOD.
MAKES THAT
STST TIME
TO COME HERE AS TIM STÜTZLE
REMAINS IN THE
BATTLE FOR IT ALONG THE BOARDS.
NORRIS POKES THAT AHEAD. DEFLEC
BATHERSON!
BROKEN UP BY PAVELSKI. HEISKANS
STICK IN COMES BROWN,SEEING-EYET
THAT ELUDES KHUDOBIN ON AND
GUSTAV
>> Gord: CHABOT TO CONNOR BROWN
ON T SIDEWAYS,
DOWN LOEY HAVE MATT MURRAY FOR
MORE YEARS UNDER  SANDERSON IS
END.
CENTNT DEFENSIVE
POSTURE BUT DRIVES HARD AROUND
THE NET, TRIES TO BACK.
NORRIS RANGES BABAN THE JETS
AND NEARLY SCORES